hello we're glad you've joined us for
today's live webinar working memory
neurophysiological basis development and
plasticity I am Christina mahalik of
levers and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots so reading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events in webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning to learn more visit libraries
com let's get started you can post
questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them in the
Q&A box which will open when you click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of this line window if
you experience technical problem seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button sounds as the top
right of the presentation window and
report your cockles by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the screen this is an educational
webinar ms offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the cee button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit I amount
delighted to present today's speaker
Christo's Constance need PhD professor
24th school of medicine Christo's
constanta Metis is a professor at Wake
Forest School of Medicine in with the
Salem North Carolina USA he received his
PhD from Johns Hopkins University they
completed those top dural training at
Yale University his research is his
research in his laboratory they
to understand how neural activity in the
cerebral cortex gets right to come to
functions such as working memory
experiments in recent years focused on
the posterior prail in dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex simultaneous neuronal
recordings for multiple microelectrodes
during performance of cognitive tasks
are addressing how these areas are
functioning organized and how experience
and learning modifies the properties of
their neurons neuronal activity in these
areas is also monitored under at
different stages of development
particularly focusing on neural
substrates of connective maturation
between the stages of adolescence and
adulthood computational and modeling
approaches are the employee to
understand the neural mechanisms that
mediate complex cognitive functions such
as the maintenance of stimulus in
working memory professor constant
meetings or now forgetting his
presentation
thank you very much for the invitation
and thank you very much for these very
kind and very comprehensive introduction
that I these are the audience an idea of
what my work is about my [ __ ] is
afternoon we'll focus on working
memories the ability to maintain
information in mind over a period of a
few seconds and also the ability to
manipulate the information according to
the needs of the moment I will focus on
them basic neurophysiological mechanisms
that maintaining working memory in the
brain and then I will talk about
experiments in my laboratory yes
examining the development of working and
abilities between the time of
adolescence or adulthood in the final
part of my lecture I will talk about
plasticity of working and learning
abilities in adulthood and how working
memory can be enhanced by training
encoded fast so I would I like to start
my presentation by your example so what
is it that I mean by the term working
them so in the next slide i will show
you as a number of series of digits and
the audience can try to remember this
print of Jesus and the call it right
let's go
alright so what was the number that i
saw them scream and if you revive six to
10 1972 88 you're correct this is so
this information although the period
that the screen was blank was maintained
somehow Iman and the part of the brain
where this information was maintained he
known as the present equipment he has
been known from human imaging
experiments for the past one year to
show that the Couture aquatics continues
to be active during the maintenance of
information memories even when nothing
is actually physically present in the
screen or the environment so we have
capitalized on these knowledge required
to understand what is the basis of
working memory at the level of the
activity of singing run in order to
address expression we use an animal
model in our research with choral
activities from isolating Iran in
non-human primates monkeys which we can
train to do working memory task similar
or analogous to the faster I asked the
audience to the form now so I'm
illustrating here the simplest of these
facts which we call the delayed response
task and when we walk you through what
does that entail a monkeys are trained
to maintain fixation at white dog on a
screen and we we ask them to do that or
require them to do that so that any
activity will occur from the brain is
not preserved by the eye movements
scavenger screen but in fact or
triggered by the visual stimuli and
representation of information in working
liver as it might be da speed skating we
saw a visual stimulus in this case is
simple a simple large player so the
Blazer is at your ovaries loving
presented in screen except for the
decision point and after the end of this
delay here the fixation form goes off
and then the monkey is trained to
indicate to us where
the screw that spoon of a beer and you
can do that simply by making my movement
it's a cod to work the location of that
seniors so this is very simple but very
awful death it allows them to find out
what is it that happened to the activity
of neurons in the prefrontal cortex as
the mighty is remembering the summer
when there is nothing else actually
physically present so it's be known also
for close to our third years now that
the activity of neurons in the
preclinical decks traxxas t lidar Shelby
Miller so let me walk you through this
diagram quickly because I will show a
few of those I will return so each one
of these diagrams in the screen
represents the responses of a single
neurons in the cerebral cortex during
the execution of the staff the x-axis
English sloth these ties the time that
it was to first vertical lines represent
the time that the scene was actually
present in the screen the time between
the second and third line is precisely
that delays are it over with the monkeys
remembering the summer and what you can
see very easily is that the activity of
this single neuron leprechaun ecliptic
is highly elevated precisely during the
time the draining of all where there is
no physical simulation screen but the
mighty is moon gaming these formulas in
memory and furthermore this activity is
specific this diagram here Kevin Owens
show earth to indicate the location of
where that sooners resulting screen and
we see this maximal activities this
national TV dinner that corresponds the
presentation of the mountain the upper
left the same neuron is not active
whereas image appeared at a duplication
in the low-rise definitive yet even in
your variables so this is
way of representing activity that
provides us with a neural correlates of
working memory neurons in the group
owner for tips active and their
specialized for different aspect of
information so that this information can
be maintained in memory even release
nothing present industry so even though
the staff is very simple and is required
is very simple response it captures a
lot of the elements of more difficult
working members death and on the right
side of the screen now I'm showing the
accuracy of the market responses which
we can measure if we look at least how
much scattered are the eye movement
forward I remember similar the top panel
here represents a responsible mighty
Frenchy you have to make and I'll move
them directly Justin incident in the
screen the middle panel represents the
responses of the same ID where a
three-second delay has been importing
the stimulus and the response and the
bottom panel representing that the
response of the monkey ran six second
delay has been imposed so what we can
see various humans are usually from
these diagrams that the more time the
longer the delay birth always that
subjects have to maintain information we
month the less accurate the responses
gob and this is precisely our experience
as as the later over which we have to
move the information increases will
become less and less accurate in our
abilities to recall the condoms in this
condition so with this with this fast in
mind then we can really test how the
four six luckily now the activity of
neurons during the delay third of the
past actually relates to the ability of
subjects do this
and these are some of us who have done
some donegal and for this is from I use
if their ancient of the delayed response
to ask where the mighty actually has
observed to stimuli presented in the
screen scheme of chemistry and she has
to determine which one of those two is
brighter which one of us is a vitally
teasing lot and after a delay period
make an idol mr. words that rumors so
these staff allows us to vary the
difficulty of of the discrimination that
might have to do and in this crap now
I'm vlogging that performance in the Y
act is the percentage of trials that the
subject performs correctly as a function
of the ratio between that Congress
taking their bridles of the two seam
lines presenting the x axis so as you
can see as the to streamline become more
and more soooo these other the
performance in this pasty gray the
activity then of nerves in the freaking
a cottage over the delay thurs of the
staff sees when the school's represent
in the non-static fields is six when
always we have the brighter of the two
do not activate in europe when the
equivalent g6 are critically when we
really very the luminance of the
school's insiders at the field in math
where the activity on decline so these
are responsive you felt that let's fight
of assisting lot and we can see that
these later activities during the past
declines exactly as a function of that
property shorter so this kind of
experiments indicate like that not all
in your general regulation directly not
only that big laser activity is specific
for the province of the similar but he
the performance all subjects from the
working memory death very much depends
on the level of maturity or the
following years and how slowly and runs
respond to you so that the outline of my
soft and the research results that i
would like to present can be broken down
into three segments in the first part of
my talk i will talk about mega millions
of working little maintenance and how
model which we call the pump a cracker
model that we have constructed allows us
to examine the fundamental properties
are the fundamental mechanisms they
released what the memory activity fee is
maintained in the brain in the second
part of my talk I will talk about how
he's working on their nothing to lose
and how these figures relating to
working memory changes between the time
between adolescence and adulthood which
we know is I'm over with a great deal of
cognitive development occurs and the
final part of my dogs I will examine and
go over expenditure was done my last
testing how working memory can be
improved by means of training by me in
practicing working memory task and what
are their consequences of this training
at a level of humor so let's start them
with a basic question how music the
witch mechanism is working memory
maintain the brain and can we create a
model to simulate resources so and
secondarily why is it that working
memory addresses degrade so quickly and
when you have to remember a series of
numbers like that we don't have this
crisp clear picture but as soon as this
disappears this is engineered in our
watermelon becomes less and less address
so who did experiments you
gross specifically these guys off person
so the basic model that most were
scientists believe that generate and
maintain personal DVD is illustrated
here let me walk you through this so
each one of these triangles in this
model the supposed to represent a single
neuron these neuron receives inputs
which we can sync off as ultimately
representing the sinners and it would
form the recognize propagated the visual
cortex and ultimately to the katonah
cortex and we simple will activate these
neurons but in addition to be sputtered
neurons are connected to each other
through this this collection so that
when the first foremost is activated it
will activate the second rounding
network and the second rod will activate
the first neurons and then the first
likely the Second Earth and this
activity will continue to reverberate in
the circuit either when the stimulus is
no longer present and we have no actual
address inputs to the circus so that
basics of this phenomenon is called
return exhibition and these brutal
recurrent network marketing reverberate
and represent information in memory very
simply with without in elaborate
structures rusty simple network
architecture we'll see vehicle so in the
case of visual spatial memory is we were
talking about working them and purely
for the spatial location of the human
we're back squared appeared in screen we
can think the network and made up of a
ring of not a nurse abstract with your
representation reverse and where they
arranged in this this ring is is meant
to represent what's yours you can
ejaculate by in represent so a student
and
volved at the zero Degree location would
be activated by similarities to the
right side of the screen they are grown
at these two thousand 70 degree rotation
would be activated by a humorous
appearing at the bottom of the screen
and the purple element again with
networks in the strata connections
neurons represents similar stimuli are
connected through the stronger
connection respond errors where as well
rather than dissimilar in life see
another further away industry they are
connected with these weaker connections
on that and the strata collection
kingdom is useless so a network like
that will very much generate activity
that means games information memories
and we can think of this process and
still cleaning out the bottom right of
the screen where the school's appears on
the screen at top a position in the
scale which five mention we call the
90-degree location then on there are
representing rotation are maximally
updated on these instances of here then
when the CMOS is no longer present this
world will continue to be active but
this activity main creek during that
just by random noise of our random
factors effectively many slide in time
and move a lesson like to do the
original location showed us at the end
of the delay purity it may have drifted
to a location etc 60 degree rotation
which precisely will then determine the
recall of the sub so where are the
subjects actually remember that similar
field will be precisely determined by
the population of the other active at
the end of the great years and i'm
showing here you grab that the schema
has drifted slightly to the right of the
original location the bc then the basic
circuit on the basic model over there an
excitation
we call that the bump cracker model
because the pic of the activity or pump
of their period it acts as an attractor
and crisp and are now its present here
is that is this model realistic is there
evidence that the real nerds in the
personal products are organized in this
fashion and the answer is yes very much
so I'm showing here some summer slides
from anatomical studies that reveal that
nurses the consequences are connected
with each other through these clusters
of connections with reciprocal
connection between them but very much
resemble and network or ring network
that I described and if we look at them
from the shortage of the cortex we span
of connections for described in the
preoperative already so the model then
is realistic and very much resembles the
real organization of connecting in their
comfort right burden as is the model
there if that is correct if the moral
issue it was evident that these laws of
our crews of working memory depends
precisely on the grip of activities to
the left or the right different life in
genetic are so we went to test this idea
in my laboratory in collaboration with
collaborators in Barcelona other copy
and peer group and so these experiments
are illustrated in this integral so if
if the bumper cracker model is correct
then all files where the peak of the
activity are scripted to the left of the
real singer you sleep here so if the
black eye view is the real singers in a
red light is well that we activity has
purpose there
will expect the subject and / the making
I even slightly to the left of the real
singer and our trials where that the
activity constructed to the right of the
relocation of the north where we would
expect the subjects to make an iron to
the right of the swimmers and now if we
go back for them and break down that the
actual I moment thinking trials where
the the muscular called slightly to the
left was likely cookbook book lies to
the relocation of counterclockwise to
the relocation and then we draw the to
travel yarns based on this clockwise and
counterclockwise locations in fact so if
systematic bias a difference in the
people of those two the blue and red
curve over here which is precisely what
would be predicted see if that the
errors of that the subject is doing
repairs precisely on the crystal
activity on the website of the right
time i should say these moral of islamic
lecture model that predicts a lot of
accuracy depends on your ability we make
some predictions are qualitative
different than a model that simply a
shows that there could be occasions on
so if the activity or just recently
became a mower ehsan goes bad then that
would achieve a number of the thermal
predictions when we multiplied in every
case in never prediction that the two
moro fun we show that extra metal data
side with the bumper crack kamal while
new speaking bus model I don't have time
to go to all the technical details we
document that newspaper but suffice it
to say that in strong external evidence
then we find non true drizzle finding
that we see a scary um in the moral
predict detail
fellow so now with Lisa knology with
this understanding mind we can call a
cab and determine how is it that the
circuit changes between the times
between adolescence and adulthood at the
time that there is a great deal of
cognitive development and what memory
abilities as loose in humans improved
greatly so the first person that we want
is regressive that he is in fact this is
also true the strong development also
occurs in 1905 and in order that we
developed all model of adolescent female
on treatment pilots what applauding here
is number of inches like a body mass the
left of Bones the size of justice the
frustration of serum structure on air
the function of x as a function of
quarters of the year as these animals
grow normally and we tracked a four
different visual for DeMarcus air they
were developing and we perform the
cereal and neurophysiological recordings
are two time points at the side born
that they're still growing and you can
see this reference still increasing here
and at the second time point where the
growth has arrested and exams have now
reached full maturity so the first
person we wanna clock is that is if in
fact working memory ability increases
between those two time points and the
way that Pacific eternity that we
allowed a animals when they were young
Therese oxytocin Foreman in practicing
the staff where as long as it was
necessary until there are cds cuatro
then we can test them at all we just
returned them to the colony we begin
practice and easier and that they simply
stayed there for four more here and then
we tested them again and allow them
again
as you go difficulties how capable world
what was that the ability to do this
kind of work memory back the fact that
we use from the trauma was the automotor
delayed response task that I described
you and a variation of this task where
we began a distractor simmers the monkey
have to remember the original scheme you
know that appears in the screen about
then we present a distress signal that
the monkey health is more to cook their
way and they might have to recall where
the initial see no superior screen and
making idle right so when we are these
guys we saw that that performance or the
percent of correct trials which one of
the staff increased political am
doubtless in this graph see the red bar
but again the assault performance with
blue bars over there the young
performance and for each one of these
panels we showed significant piloting an
increase in performance in golfers so
that verifies our hypothesis that in
fact might be still not just like humans
improved in what their abilities between
a vampire essence in adulthood we've
been examined what is it that they
change in their city in the katana
projects between so speak on board and
what we found was that the biggest and
most significant was the activity during
the delay third of the time so all of
the time period that the market a a crew
member is fumes which are significant
Iorek ad in rats in adulthood that in
the same animals in a young age which is
shown here in blue on the dock and in
terms of this dispersal stimulus we saw
that again the adult animals were able
to generate a higher level of activity
that propaganda casino that the monkeys
can't remember all the restreamers that
the mighty task is more is respected she
knows that they have is one so this
difference the square the adult son in
the youngster chemicals and I will also
try to contain
now she's the young and the adult
animals differ greatly in terms of the
overall levels of performance an
important control analysis we got to do
here is to make sure that any
differences that we found an activity
mr. concordance was not simply the
effect of performance it was not simply
because they the adult animals perform
the task and higher level so i would
keep these analyses by plotting the
firing range generated by patrolling
near us as a function of that proportion
of questions so is a faction of the
level of performative that I'm surely
NASA we found that related activities
God's depends on the level of
performance however quickly if we
brought the adults data so here from
rest of these were apart and beyond what
would be predicted based on the level of
performance alone and we should sure we
show that the difference between a young
adult and more specifically delayed
relative we found no significant
difference for the response to the
school itself in the adult animals
compared to the other another way you
think that'll another way of controlling
that is that when we compared the
session of the young animals where they
perform the back so we use that the best
day of their range of performance or we
compare that with a warm days of the
adult animals the cabin would generally
two groups obsessions so in fact it's
rated for the general performance so you
look for formats sessions we see that
the adult performer projects again there
is a higher level of delays vertically
van the young cassandra good so this
results then give us some ideas and
description of what has happened between
those two stages but that implies
answered was one of them underlying
mechanisms that allow that
generally these difficulties in order
Griffith between an analysis of what we
call the printed connectivity between us
which I Irish like you're very flat
preservative so we consider to your arms
in episode four days off or either the
young or the adult animals we can record
simultaneously from disneyland by
bathroom to micro electrodes in the
brain and we can measure than the
spheres of action potentials that is
Tina generate and then we can look at
super science of others do not which is
a measure of how tightly these neurons
are connected with each other how strong
is the connections that tribes or stream
lastima chemistry so when we do this
analogy them and plot or job we find
that for the adult freakin aquatic shown
here in blue this peak of the
correlation analysis which expresses the
strength of connections between two
neurons within the pre computed was
significantly higher than the young
couple quarters it is the other child
here and there be a fine systemically
significantly higher strength of
connections between neurons in the
adults and young personal use so the
results usually implies that the
projects between that time of adolescent
and darkest increases in the strength of
collections and increasing the rubble or
the Kiwi the generous and this is
associated with the increase in working
memory ability now a question that you
know it personally have here that
working memory of belief is very limited
you know that I show you're single can
numbers which is equivalent all the
cell's number but if I had a secret
recording
that I ask you to remember your turn
second per second very few people if any
people will be able to do that why is it
that working memory abilities ensure
limited and then it is so limited I is
there anything that we can do about it
and can we improve these was mental
capacity in adulthood so in order to
show you some provide some inside of y1
camera capacity so limited I would like
to show a video nails available in
YouTube these are two Roberts users to
google home robots that are talking to
each other so let's see the video now if
we may you are lying about being a bar
well you are unpredictable
I prefer to be unpredictable it keeps
things fresh
but how do you manage to stay
unpredictable
you did it
didn't
yes you did stop lying
I'm not lying you're imaginating thing
what's imaginating
sorry I did not understand what's
imaginating
understand what I meant with one it goes
downhill from there so these are two in
some way these are two highly
intelligent Roberts two highly
intelligent systems of artificial
intelligence type when we hear the dog
they are profoundly an adult and the
reason that they are not showing in
order don't sound very smart is that
because they don't have and working
every every response of the robert
refers to whatever was heard last
there's really no ability that these
always have to focus on one line of
thought and really talk about it in
focus there there and focus their mental
resources on it so this is how i became
whatever their what now is very critical
in our ability to maintain of the art
rainfall and filtering your relevant
things in filtering distraction just
focusing on a few ideas reside yes it is
really beneficial for us and it's in
photographs can prove what memory and if
we if there are conditions that
compromise whatever it is very important
to have some tools to do that so we have
done that by training monkeys to do a
more challenging work in the reduction
what i've shown so far which very much
mimics the kind of training that are now
is commercially available and clinically
available for patients that have two
total total problems because lesions or
strokes and in this training that has
been proven beneficial at least for
clinical progression so here is our
version that over kilogram we trained
animals to fixate on the screen we
display a visual slingers in the delay
period when we began the second fingers
and if the self-esteem of here that the
same location as the first in cos if you
then after another delay period to Troy
sockets are going to appear and the
subject will have to make an ad movement
to the green Coruscant he's on the other
hand of second schools in the statements
were the nomads then after the second
delay period where the torus objects
appear exactly we'll have to make a man
movement to the flute art so in order to
perform this task the subject has to
remember where this first image appears
yes you are moving data memory and just
make a conversion about with a simple
seamless and then make this choice
between the blue and green target which
is a very difficult task because a lot
of effort or animal team after that but
the score with training design a most
needy staff you can present the exact
same stream line with exact exactly the
same styling or got the same sequence
and we are the subject of this case only
have to maintain education you don't
have to link in anything what man would
have never been trained to do anything
and just have to sit quietly there and
just look at this team lot and reward
them just not as an organization so by
comparing the experience in the cupola
cortex between the fully trained scale
can be part of a really nice space we
can find out what is it that training
can induce in the personal project and
how is the activity of neurons exchange
I is following this working memory so in
order to find yourself it actually
proved important to you a breakdown the
responses of different parts of the
Potomac River so we decided the persona
cortex in this dorsal and ventral
subdivisions and furthermore we
subdivided ghoshal subdivisions in the
posterior and meet dorsal and here goes
on for the polar regions and subdivided
the ventral Peconic or the fingers or
sphere
interior area so using the subdivision
recordings of a large number of grams
for multiple monkey and then we
quantified the cell activity of neurons
for different types of stimuli here I'm
showing a very simple Mary we discover
it in the number of people raised it is
the simplest way to quantify the protein
is simply by comparing the maximum and
minimum response to different types of
sea life and calculating itself to the
English now let's see how the responses
nurse giver subdivisions referred in the
completely naive state in the animal
that has not been trained to be anything
in terms of responsiveness the
percentage of the earth that responded
to any similar that represent them we
found that the dose of the konica cortex
about forty percent of nursing as those
of the 20 questions were responses to
run but only ten percent of the bench of
the chronic rejection responded TV
series in terms of relativity we find
that that spatial selectivity was
greater in the dorsal persona projects
that in the ventral people critique and
response elsevier edition features
system are four different shapes which
greater in the ventral premotor cortex
time rewards in the doors of the
protocol in terms of the I'm fearing for
supersonic or text when we see that more
for sure areas are daring more
responsive to cinema you show greater
higher level five Ray's in for here
areas that Indian tier areas and in the
mist years were indicated eating those
two and we also found that forcier
errors are more selective personalized
for each one of these females as a
village facial shape and color because
here areas have higher subsidies than
the meat or answer
finally we find that for secure areas of
shorter response languages and anterior
it is observed here the cumulative
distribution of distant nerves or
different response latencies across
there and again we find that the
inferiors have the longest legacies in
also the anterior errors has the largest
receptive field which is shown here as a
proportion of response to that location
so without going into exhaustion details
we definitely some obligation some
factional organizations both in terms of
think oh it goes up the conical X in
terms of aunty reinforcing of the solar
projects which was important when we
examine effective training in the area
now in the course of these experiments
are in completely naive animals we found
out that about twenty percent of nerves
that responded the visual scene life
also generated persistent discharges in
naive animals so I started be solved by
your presenting personality as a neural
correlative working memory and here I'm
showing you an instance of reciprocity
generated even when the animal is not
trained to discuss that the meeting in
fact but i think this finding is not
incompatible with our addition of
working over what the memory means were
able to remember seeing even if we're
not typically choose ahead of time to
remember that in a second to them and
otherwise it's you know general
requirements for which memory working
memory will not be all that useful class
and we go about our everyday life and we
encounter all kinds in life that may or
may not turn out to be important for us
double Park Service oh we've seen all of
them and this understanding we can find
out what does that happen after training
in the Pretoria the way we did this
experiment is that we sampled different
locations in the pecan
for this before training and then we
sample again a large number of occasions
in the clockwise applicant do not have
the ability to crack the exact same not
all of the spirit of training but we
sampled in an unbiased fashion we
collected data from a large number one
so we can do conversions at the level of
population so here that I will summarize
the the changes that occurred after
cream since launch of the percentage of
mirrors are activated by the stream life
during the school's presentation to and
during the flavors these are the day
events are you and what form already
card game after claiming we see a
general increase in the percentage of
neurons that respond similar in other
words after Ukraine if you and what you
remember that and we practiced that and
you become proficient in it we see a
greater percentage of neurons in your
personal effects that are now active and
wish for peace in life during the
tradition of the back than before trade
but this is not indiscriminate in fact
we see this increase was greater
proportion for the ventricular cortex
and was greater for the delay sir namak
unification here in Congress a source of
katana cortex particular during the
school's presentation here really is not
exhibit a great deal of difference so
the social cut architects will represent
team life even when these are completely
irrelevant they have no commitment for
for some of those drugs that were active
during the task we see a general
increase inspiring so those are the
Spartans a scroll choked by more action
potential asset rating but somewhat
paradoxically when we look at chu
so is giving him her so he can fool us
we saw that after training there is a
general increase in activity if we were
to compare the first humans and the one
stimulus response after claiming this in
fact is not include the children and in
fact it may have declined a little that
where is that we preferred is finding
that after training we have activity of
a lot of runs that represent all kinds
of different things represent the move
at the monkey has you remember the
represent is this representation of the
blue and green doggies are going to show
up later that you know what is imagine
what is not mad so all this information
is also active in the persona context
after claiming but is not necessarily
representing a stimulus itself and this
this is shown here again if we looked at
peace is another way of expressing
exactly what i described now look at the
Disco bility advert ability of the
cylinder on accident that discriminated
in the stimulus this is not increased
African impactive slightly decreases all
right so the result describe that
changes as happened in the Potomac
effects after creighton but it doesn't
quite capture how is it that we are able
to form these fast applications that we
didn't know before so to understand that
these changes we use a another variation
of the staff that provided a clearer
picture of this process andres pass it
might be have to remember the different
shapes that we saw on the screen and yes
it besides each to see why presenting
sequence of the same shape or not and if
there are different shapes standard
we'll have to make a nivel them to a
blue Taurus target exactly as I
described for the central version of
this as well so diagram them with again
what has half
respected our cognition so the upper
left quad represents the ability of
neurons before training is move in after
trading in red to represent information
about the seniors identity the shape of
the single detail and you can see that
this is not change very much upgrading
at all underneath of the values of these
shapes that we use are very easy to tell
apart from telling you don't really need
any specific training to tell if a
square shape is different men appreciate
it Mike variable recognize this already
before anything whatever on the right
side of this crowd however i'm showing
the information contained in earth
representing precisely is much more
maths compare after climbing this is
essentially absent in your tea after
claiming the ability of your community
school in between not matter much almost
approaching a hundred percent so all
that has happened at the grammys the
training in fact has resulted in exactly
this changing luckily because recently
that was not present before that is now
present and if we were to take a step
deeper injunction that's how that came
about we would look at this running
before so in this item every point to
another potential single neuron the
y-axis represents the maximum
information that this mural represents
with respect it is not known as the
corium and we see that fired acclaim
most of the neurons so passengers and
runs represent very little information
the burke last year of this pass
completion so the mighty price granny
really is not thinking in terms of math
and on math this contest don't really
have any meaning specific for for for my
team but after cleaning what we see is
that about ten percent of the neurons
now represent highly significant
information about real life
which was not there before so in other
words was in words of the floor the new
call me back when you learn a task of
depends on what memories and good
example for that would be pseudo cool or
game like that what happens is that
you'll note better in recognizing the
school I the numbers that are using
again after grating them before screen
you can still telling knives from
attorney Park that's such a trivial task
you don't need to be done what the
customer after you learn to do be
something crazy because you've got about
ten percent of the neurons in your
prefrontal cortex become highly
selective for the special permission and
will signal is a particular calmer
numbers or vertical line of numbers is
correct or make sense or not you see the
asking your friend and you take that one
step further final step further if we
were to look at what we learn that
become very selective where the staff
information do is not that the only
resident passed information in fact this
your arms are up again other parameters
Wilson's here in from three different
that were very selected for this matter
imagination but the Savior's also
respond to stimuli has all kinds of
other information so it's not as you
know after practicing again you know you
have murder dedicated to do start alone
and forget everything else but in fact
you have incorporation of unification in
your circuits at multiplexes other types
of information knowledge passed as well
so I will fit if I thought by showing
what is it the next open interest in the
next step in this experiment that was
actively doing now is to have chronic
recordings in the play and have my
collectors directly implanted in the
brain that can at Clark activities earth
animals learn to do that so we can see
on a daily basis is as subjects practice
and do better wanted it that actually
happens in apical aequitas Julian sizes
accredited so I will stop my
presentation here and briefly summarize
the findings of experience in their life
so I show your first at north in the
prefrontal cortex maintain these charges
through the current connection and then
activity script besides as the animal
testament daily sensation in errors we
show that the increase in working memory
performance in adolescence he's
associated with increased to solo
quad-core purses material and we show
furthermore that we change in a lesson
is associated with maturation of
connecting synaptic connections between
people the world finally in the last
part of my god I'll show you that
trading whatever that recruit more
neurons increases relational activities
but reduces the advert selectivity of
nurse will be specific in line families
as earners at learning in the shortening
with emergence of a small population of
highly selective not a good specific
class that has seen Craig I will stop
here and we'll decide the people who dis
is a thermos my skills are wake forest
and groceries and also my collaborators
in whispers in another institution I
showed here finally for those in the
audience who would like to learn more
about this topic which is a review paper
that our laboratories bubbling
specialist this is freely available and
more details can be found there and I
was again more resources can be found in
the geography of Islam thank you very
much that was my first edition thank you
for men circumstance needy for your
informative presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how submit
questions simply type them in the Q&A
box sounds by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left is press
pation window we will answer as many
questions as time permits so without
hesitation let's help into the first
question professor the first question of
the day asks your talk focused on the
prefrontal cortex are there other parts
of the brain that are involved in
working memory
this is a very good question and this is
a very topical question in fact there is
an active debate about the role of
different parenting that in watching of
it what I can say unequivocally and most
people agree is that the burner network
of theirs are active during working
hours from Joe banner is a generation
system activity the joint action with
also steering the delay period of
working emerged as if the competence is
no Lord properties is connected without
posterior parietal cortex into your
temporal cortex and also subcortical
areas that is a basal ganglia and a
medial midi ghoshal nucleation of the
ground so there's a broader network of
areas that are activated your work
memories and if there's any damage in
any part of these networks then person
will show working memory deficits in
fact is strong current levels but this
is the case thank you for your answer
the next question has adolescence is
often associated with impulse enmity and
for decision-making did you see similar
terms in the monkeys
give us another person that we were very
interested in answering I didn't have
time to present the results in my talk
but the short answer is yes very much so
we designed a a multi version of the
marshmallow path that is knowing the
human literature and that is invertible
passive if you show it to you like a
four-year-old child one marshmallow and
he too tired of the option you can
either have the marshmallow now or you
can wait for five minutes to reach case
you can have to mark millar's some kids
are able to do that great apartment but
a lot of kids you know that they can't
do that because they cannot resist and
they are they will they will take the
marshmallow nearly so we would use a
fewer version of the past to see how
impulsive a lesson monkeys are any
second resist they can delay
gratification for a larger reward and in
fact we saw that in our lesson monkeys
just like humans a poor impulse control
and the more mature and more the fully
grown adult life is a better able gravy
options and and and choose one is more
beneficial so this is an arrow research
that were very much interested in
pursuing in the future well thank you
for that answer our third question of
the day as I was wondering how long does
it take to trained monkeys to perform
these cognitive task
the Grizzlies also a critical question
when training human initiatives the
you're going to test you can give them
verbal instructions we can tell them
look at the first in earth way to see
their second signatures are shown as a
first and then make an odd movement to
the blue target or the green targets and
maybe takes a little bit of training a
few trials be getting to that part of
that and really internalize the
instructions but few months are able to
master that very quickly you know with
mike is unfortunately we don't have the
ability to communicate verbally so we
have to save them using operant
conditioning letters step by step by
step until they get to this level Lisa
process that takes several months and
all the determine that I described you
really take months a year sometimes you
really playing an animal to be a complex
Africa thanks
okay and it looks as though we only have
time for one more question today in that
question asks you talked about the
changes in brain activity after training
in a working memory task can
intelligence be improved with cognitive
training this is another very topical
question is a very strong debate in the
literature on whether normal adult human
by practicing in cold assassins
practical thousands wirework memory
whether that benefit can transfer into
general goal different actions and in
truth intelligence so this is
controversial some people believe that
it is possible is another handset maybe
for economic growth not possible but I
would emphasize that at least for
certain populations for children with
ADHD with people who have suffered
stroke or people who have suffered a
brain injury working memory training he
is in fact beneficial and can have
benefits and it can improve general Kong
dysfunction so I mean I think there's a
lot to learn about the mechanisms that
generate these beautiful good run thank
you for this working once again I'd like
to thank you professor contents
annuities for your presentation do you
have any final comments that you'd like
to leave us today the bits all one of us
all grout here you know I think the
audience can get more information from
you know that I provided and look
forward to participating in the future
excellent I would like to thank the
audience for joining us today and bake
lab ruse for today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
region in 2017 library flow learn you
via email when it is available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's event this is christian
Mihalik with levers and we'll see you
here next time goodbye